[Music]
22 year old zinn
coco saw is fatally wounded
next to him a woman he'd met hours
earlier at a protest
she told him to stay back
but he didn't
what you're about to see is the killing
of one of many civilians
at the hands of myanmar's authorities
sky news has analyzed videos and photos
from the city of myeong-jae
to piece together the events leading up
to zin koko saw's
death
[Music]
wednesday the 3rd of march 2021
the bloodiest day in myanmar since the
military took
power in an illegal coup
before the day is over at least 38
protesters will have been killed
at demonstrations across the country
among them in the city of mingjae
xin kokozo
ming jae is just south west of mandalay
myanmar's second largest city
that morning zin ko is one of hundreds
of protesters gathering on a main road
national highway 2.
just before half past 9 this video shows
protesters walking along the highway
at least eight police and military
vehicles arrive
they turn around right in front of the
protesters
as this truck turns we catch a glimpse
inside
the patch on this soldier's right arm
shows
their troops from myanmar's infantry
on the left arm of the soldier opposite
we can see
another insignia it's hard to make out
but in this image taken on the same day
in the area
the same patch is clearer they're
soldiers from the 88th
light infantry division a part of the
army
notorious for its brutality
the weapons they're carrying also give
us a sense
of what's to come here on the right
one soldier carries a single shot
grenade launcher
it can be used for tear gas human rights
observers tell us the soldier on the
left
is carrying an mas rifle
the army's sniper rifle
is now just after 10 protesters are
gathering around the clock tower at the
intersection
of the main road in lenfitt street
so far from videos sky news has seen
there's no sign of conflict between
the military and the demonstrators at
this point
nine minutes later this footage is being
filmed by a volunteer
medical assistant the police are in
formation at the north end of national
highway
2 facing the protesters
a group of soldiers is behind in support
then some protesters seem to head
towards the police
shots are fired they quickly turned back
[Music]
the police and army line has moved up
towards the intersection
some protesters are behind a makeshift
barricade in the road
a police warning sounds protesters must
leave the area
shots are fired some take
two people run across the intersection
carrying something
the video is too graphic to show
his shirt is covered in blood his head
falls back
almost hitting the tarmac you can hear
the panic
as they carry him to an ambulance
but it's already too late
[Music]
later pictures are taken of zinko's
parents
of the vigil held at the place where he
died
and that evening crowds gather at the
place where zinco died
at the end of the bloodiest days so far
in the battle
for myanmar